the blues all occupy williams
jean eric woodside package will delete
european commission's europe is a
newbie maurice joly they have this jack
of all right
you'll find stringer prize money
foods initiative be
faced jean-eric yes let's say rihanna
lithium near nor  robben so we do you
bad biotechnology and not for nuclear
physx rapine de show is for you
[Music]
ayem dit l'aïe dit oui comme jean eric
bâtés double figures of 800 hp innovation
department at toyota a
google commission esteem jean ritzenthaler
bong touch  ruiz knowledge watch out two
controllers seventy seven biglione you with
such program one of the world is money
the major world newspapers technical
the best paid ayew billionaire 7
very very big program one drop
technologies of the future there was jacques
dubé lyonnaise was put at our disposal
commission made hot famine pictures of
view new delhi work and organs six
hours with mamadou mbaye
this absolute ordeal of their duo
the delay between the future program
of leucate understood example given to the
brochures of being do you have to discover
seven planet s  open to all and 370
as well as Chadian suppliers and
the fair play boy of the road kills no
solution plastic products and we have
sex with the study of plastic thrones
the same daily pro little tigers and
nephew mixed willy claes example
the economy  by koffi koffi koffi 2 tab
[Music]
jean-eric you are a real
jack-of-all-trades before being in
charge of finding tools at the
general secretariat of the commission and
you are in particular at the origin of the corps
european solidarity originally it was
the president of the commission jean
claude juncker who announced the creation
of a european solidarity corps during
his speech on the state of the union in
2016 and the idea is  indeed to
create a European program which allows
young Europeans up to the age of
30 to make themselves available for
solidarity actions, which in the
member states of the European Union
is not an entirely
new idea  European volunteers have
already existed for about twenty years but
the president's idea was really to
try to cover more
areas
all the member states people may
be a little older and to really
allow them to demonstrate their concerns
and their desires for solidarity the idea
is to propose by 2020 to one hundred
thousand young Europeans to spend
a few months up to a year in a
member state
often in another member state in order
to effectively help in the
social field  in the field of health in
the humanitarian field
the seeland field can be
environmental ecological there are
a lot of requests from young
europeans where their effect is on you but me
I have like me I have proposed to my sons
to register I think that  'they are
registered I'm still not sure they
have been selected but my sons
have registered too, would I
have done it young in my opinion yes
Europe generates a lot of questions
that you know and we have gathered
a few questions that we were able to find online
there are concerns there are hopes
and I wanted you to react
the first is on the european plinth
of social rights by bruno he has a bit of
this acerbic comment that the
plinth brings  european social rights
answer short answer nothing generated a
little longer
this european pillar of social rights
is first of all
to show europeans that europe
is not just the internal market
europe is not just the internal market
liberal economy which is sometimes highly criticized in
public discourse in many member states
for the president of the commission for
the european institutions the
social dimension and issues related
to employment in particular are also at the heart
of the european project are at the heart
of the  values ​​carried by by europe
to be a little more concrete I will
give you two provisions which have
been approved by all the institutions
the first is a provision which
establishes a minimum wage in europe its
share is ultra natural in a
member state  such as france or belgium
for example where the
minimum wage(s) has existed for a very long time
this is not the case for all the
member states so there it is a point of
reference where many
member states now have the  question
of a minimum wage but in a way I
think more important also in terms of
future policy there
is the question of a state there is the
principle which is posed in this in this
base of a universal minimum income
which must allow  to all
European citizens to live in dignity
that is obviously an
extremely ambitious principle which is not
yet operational which is
currently being tested there are experiments
in belgium in finland and not in
other member states where
we are actually testing  how such a
minimum income works i have another
rice comment that they share one of his dreams
on twitter and i'll tell you i
think you'll like it
could we imagine a train line
that would connect  the netherlands spain
france to hungary via
northern italy greece to bulgaria
romania slovakia poland and
estonia by train whose name would be
the european union
that's a  nice it's a nice dream which
in part reality a it's almost a
network that your your reader the nanny
presents and it exists in part there is this
European transport network to this
European mobility network which exists
today
or in  in any case in the
European policies which was put in place in
2013 and which is both
infrastructure because indeed
trains must run on
rails and often we have difficulty it is
to connect the networks  national
so that's what the european policy
is to build these infrastructures
which connect the national networks of the
big tunnels for example like the
brenner or the lyon turin in france but
then it's also to have trains
running on these  on its rails and
this is where I think the real challenge is
to have rail operators who
offer their services and the creation
of a Europe of rail is also to
allow that there are obviously already
services that existed  there's a bit of this
image of the orient-express or of these
big night trains which are
the European collective imagination which
I think is behind this question and
that's obviously first and foremost the
operators who have to  proposing it
is not the commission that is going to set
up rail services, but
it is true that it is a dream that I will
very willingly share and which is
also somewhat supported by the
European parliament and the commission since the
European parliament has  proposed to set
up a
1 this interest is happening feroe this guinea pig
or to propose to any European who
reaches the age of majority to have
for a few months say that this
Scheldt rail pass watches or
allowing him to travel in  europe
i don't know how old you are roman
depot such work or too old for the
past today may be too
young to have made interest in
your youth but it's true that my
generation we all had  a
good interrail pass that we bought but we
all worked we talked we all
crossed europe and you exchange
currencies you are extraordinary me I
am me I went down to greece from
strasbourg when I was 15 or 16  years
have passed when we arrive
at the border with slovenia then
croatia is then belgrade it was an
extraordinary adventure and it is not
stupid at the time we saw life
without a visa it was really quite
remarkable
[  Music]
strasbourg alter had family at my mind
engine to a big sale to reach
but the features of a sinister years so
that marthe and children under five
work carry a slime and
francophile of the man of fate ski
grosse mutahar zeb  at dolce francia dubai
family set up a whole
palette in two stages of flours
buying some 300 at total
romania we will be there below we do not film
chapatte clinton offered a cat lady yesterday
that the t notes sung on the dow
jones is progressing by 4 in the franc zone
crash
now i put so many men and
richard zink on sat and found out to
regroup game project is a garden
project five she cries happy we have
room can park one of the families
that are looking for-  you nature jean hine pascal
because live all that at the moment
dry it theory a hump metals apolitical
group
you were I barely in bathurst ortschitt
stotch france usa 6 naturist new
dimension
but theoretically we will not do under
contract with astana
but the  commission was able to blow back
to the mythical stadium of amman phone and
phone and jews and down in terre-sainte
girls filmed impact and spirit frights
louvaines a task all saturday to a
pit for these bruises on sunday and dedicated
a frequency of articles because
I like the blues do via benoît anne
andreu a short night happened we
respect while a flash in the pan kong
and at the bottom of this trail organized on your
map shields china you want you to you
sebastian minister we explain to damascus
director was speaks like a commission
or peg to put a ball when
colleagues dare not cross it
professional frito chips lay your
hands and day like that a future girl
very tall single game anxious movie
put some kind of floodgates dialysis
fragments  of a final notebook was also
canon said that the north as a
normal tyrant in charge of the mainframe thailand
und wir haben will have a class
worst aspyr media at path-green dunst
sitting on a new asylum video game
which is sum we  or motto of the
marines palio episode provides people
[Music]